[Musique]
et ouvrir les kick off the beginning of
the human league soit des flics what
makes balance mais nous vivons surtout
carrick de dvd ou marc ohlala games to
be actifs football
[Musique]
nambiar quand même à bout en pleine
forme pour la scène plus bien cias du
swiss re l'un de ses leaders
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
la chasse à la baleine in a yellow
banine ça va profiter à tous les
candidats figurent le soudan et la face
à l'eire pour nous faire éliminer
terrible et le fibd notre homard à
toulouse elle mène de mark hart lane où
albert court n 2 celui d'à coups répétés
rigal où elle courait le cm a répété
lundi sa femme admise à colmar
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]